j'aimerais maintenant vous parler des
programmes de notre soirée que vous
passerez en compagnie de mon ami martin
chardon c'est un beau film que vous
verrez à 20h35 un film de jean daniel le
pôle et l'acrobate je vous en reparlerai
de ce film dans une vingtaine de minutes
comprendrez pourquoi tout à l'heure et à
22h10 les impressions de tournage des
français en écosse mort en direct
en effet une équipe de la bbc de glace
qu à filmer durant huit semaines le
tournage du film de bertrand tavernier
la mort en direct avec romy schneider et
max von sydow et ce sont ces images que
vous pourrez suivre ce soir avec nous à
22h10 et nous terminerons la soirée avec
une émission que vous connaissez bien de
pierre petit réalisé par gérard exode
figaro si figaro là avec la soprano
michèle koeman esther et le bar et
anthony amis râteau tout de suite c'est
la vie présentée par noël mamère et
claude marcotte et je vous retrouve dans
20 minutes
à tout à l'heure